in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for September 6, on which we commemorate
the miracle of the Archangel Michael in Colossae.
On the 6th of the month, we celebrate the miracle brought by the Archangel Michael
at Honae in Frigia.
The great Archangel Michael showed his good will and watchful care for the human race
in many ways before the coming of our Savior into this world.
And since then, the tokens of his love have been ever greater for Christians.
When he was preaching the gospel in Frigia, the Apostle John foretold that the Archangel
would be sent by God to a place called Karethopa, now Kaya Deepi, near Lake Saldar,
where, soon after, a spring miraculously welled up that healed every sickness.
A beautiful little church dedicated to the Archangel Michael was built at the place
by one of the many faithful who came there in thanksgiving for the cure of his daughter.
80 years later, a young man called Archipus from Yerapolis settled there wanting to
lead the ascetic life and to serve as sacristan.
His fervent love of God was soon rewarded by the gift of working miracles,
but the wonders that were wrought and the grace that abounded at the miraculous spring
angered the devil, who unleashed the envy of the surrounding pagans.
They insulted and attacked Archipus several times and one night tried to block up the spring,
but the invisible presence of the Archangel prevented them.
Next, they tried to change the course of the river flowing nearby,
so as to drown the church and the faithful dwelling there,
but neither did this attempt meet with success.
Finally, they diverted two rivers and made a dam to form a lake above the church
and were breaking through its bank, order to engulf the church in waters.
When the Archangel Michael appeared to Archipus, he reassured the holy man,
and in the likeness of a column of fire confronted the raging torrent as it tore down the hill.
When it reached him, the Archangel claved the rock with his staff,
creating a natural gorge through which the waters flowed out of the way of the church.
Ever since the rock swallowed the river, the place has been called Chonai,
meaning melting pot or funnel, to the glory of God, and in honor of our protector,
the Holy Archangel Michael.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.